yes it's everyone's favorite psychotic
doll don't worry you still have a
special place in my heart
Chucky I'm talking of course about the
lovable puka the one that has the second
lowest IMDB rating for into the dark
season one now I might be in the
minority here but I actually like the
first puka and the fact that other into
the dark additions like new year new you
and pure have higher scores boggles my
mind by the way if you haven't seen my
takedown of new year new you definitely
check it out but today we're gonna be
taking a deep dive into Phuket ooh so
pour yourself in gasoline because here
we go hookah two starts with the
inventor of puka le Burgess hard at work
fixing the original puka doll will later
find out that Ellie used to go to the
same school as our protagonist Derek and
his friends not only that she worked at
s CI spectacular contraptions Inc the
same company Derek ends up getting a job
at she brought her idea puka to the
company and they bought it from her but
when they wanted to go with changes to
the doll well Ellie went a bit crazy I
can't make puka without me okay and I
are one Ellie's husband David played by
Star Trek the next generations will
Wheaton isn't too happy when he finds
out she had to be escorted out by
security and when he calls the doll
stupid she puts on the pooka masks and
stabs him mercilessly with a pair of
scissors then lights herself on fire
in fact Benny later remarks that the
flames got so hot that it melted the
mask to her face fast forward one year
where we meet Derek a down-and-out
writer from New York who is currently
being hashtag canceled for a book where
he exposed popular social media
influencers specifically a big youtuber
type personality called Jax Jax ordered
his army of followers to go after him
essentially killing his book sales and
forcing him out of the big city having
to take a job as a lowly copywriter
working for the company that makes
pookas we also get this shot of him
sucking on a necklace a necklace given
to him by his hometown crush Susan as a
goodbye present he may have left for the
big city but a part of him still holds
on to this small-town life and the
future
he could have had was Susan ever think
what would have happened if we stayed
together
Derek ends up staying at his childhood
friends house Matt and Molly's just
until he can get on his feet his job at
s CI starts tomorrow and Amir the
[ __ ] GM has everyone working like Mad
Men since there's only one week until
the pooka redesign is unveiled Derek
even finds out that his ex Susan works
at s CI a relationship he'll try to
cultivate over the course of the film
and if working with your ex wasn't
stressful enough Derek finds out that
someone has vandalized his car well
later find out this was done by Andy
head of social media for sei and a loyal
follower of Jax at Derek's welcome home
party the topic of the viral Momo
challenge is brought up remember Momo
the Momo intimidates and threatens those
who don't follow its instructions and
the final challenge can be anywhere from
harming to killing yourself hey at least
it's not the tide pod challenge online
people destroy Derek's life so if he can
find a new way to [ __ ] with them by
creating a new challenge he's all-in and
with him being a writer he gets quick to
work and creating the pooka challenge in
which subjects must eat pieces of ash
dawn the pooka mask in sing and dance
the pooka song he even comes up with a
brilliant backstory that Ellie's family
was linked to the Salem witch trial and
that her violent death forced her evil
spirit to be trapped within the original
puka doll overnight the challenge goes
viral the irony for Derek here is that
it's the most influential thing I've
ever written and I can't even take
credit for it
meanwhile Jax who completed the pooka
challenge live streams his own murder
when puka attacks him with a pair of
scissors the same weapon Ellie used to
kill her husband it's also funny that
people comment how this is a great prank
over blue and red drinks yes the two
colors of pookas eyes derek and susan
catch up but he's called out by her
since he left town he didn't bother to
keep in touch with his friends and only
when he needed their help did he come
crawling back the reason why he never
deleted his social media especially
after the fallout from his book is that
he wanted to be seen well he got what he
wished for just not in the way he wanted
meanwhile Susan who I guess decides to
drink and drive is attacked by puka
maybe
why he wrote naughty naughty on the side
of her car she survives the attack and
later that night Derek finds out that
people have been adding to the legend of
puka in fact the more people start
believing in puka the more changes
happen to it in real life apparently it
can now teleport and sports these new
claws there's also a fun into the dark
Easter Egg here with this ad for
treasure a pop star from season two's My
Valentine with one day left to go before
the new puka unveil derek can't sleep he
reads the news that someone murdered
their entire family after doing the
pooka challenge and blamed puka for it
derek has unwittingly created a viral
challenge that has now killed people he
has essentially become the thing he
wanted to end in his book a dangerous
influencer unable to finish this speech
while late at work Derek is attacked by
this new and improved puka who now
sports claws and has the ability to
teleport just like the internet claimed
Derek manages to corral his friends to
go after puka and put his spirit to rest
and they think they know exactly where
to go Benny traced those mysterious
texts Derek received to Andi who just
happens to be at Ellie's murder house
but when they search that they find his
body buried under a pile of pookas
before they're viciously attacked out
match the gang retreats to the bar to
think of a new plan Molly argues that
the Internet has created a Tulpa a
spiritual companion from Tibetan
mysticism which is like a wheeled
imaginary friend but in this case not so
much a friend if they can shift the
internet's perception of the pooka maybe
they can stand a chance at killing it at
this point the Internet has created
what's known as the apocalypse the idea
that at the pooka unveiling all the old
pookas will come to life and kill
humanity as revenge for trying to change
/ redesign it in order to stop this
apocalypse they'll need to change the
story and what better way than by giving
puka a weakness Derek rates a new post
about how the apocalypse can be stopped
by killing the original doll using
scissors the same weapon Elli used to
kill her husband the post conveniently
goes viral meaning that if they can
destroy the pooka doll with those
scissors they can stop the apocalypse
makes perfect sense right and in a final
confrontation between Derek and the
pooka he's able to stab the doll and
puka at once shattering it to pieces his
final line before killing it being your
cancelled just like how he was canceled
by the internet but the big twist at the
ending is that their plan ultimately
fails the new redesign puka goes on a
rampage sparking all the unopen pukas to
come alive you see the internet just
won't let puka die the credits have
these animated shots of the crew taking
on the pookas but that's it for the
ending I personally found it unfulfilled
there's no real resolution and Derek's
character arc about not caring about the
town wasn't nearly as fleshed out as it
should have been we don't really get to
see this change in him as a character
throughout the entire film for example
he gets called out by Susan for not
caring about his friends and in the next
scene he basically realizes it and
that's the end of his art character arcs
aren't supposed to change from one
dynamic to the other like a light switch
we have to see the character with one
world view at the start and have it
gradually tested throughout the entire
film until the character makes a choice
to change
Derek's character arc should have been
that he's come back to Spring Valley
just for a bet then will leave his
friends again after things have cooled
down but as he goes throughout his
journey he should learn that friends are
more important than Fame I just didn't
really get that in this movie at its
core however puka 2 is a commentary on
the toxicity of Internet fandom and
canceled culture how easily we can be
manipulated online and how that
manipulation can manifest in the real
world we've seen it happen like the
Slender Man stabbing back in 2014 it's
bleak ending however suggests we have a
long way to go before we can put a stop
to this until then we'll have to keep on
fighting even if those things we fight
are as crazy as imaginary dolls thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and leave me a
comment below but what you thought of
Koopa tube you can also follow me on
twitter at think story whitey until next
time remember daddy loves you very much